good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight you may have noticed
that joe biden announced today a new
front in his ongoing war against
america's middle class biden didn't
frame it that way of course democrats
rarely say what they mean they tell you
it's about something else in this case
biden told us it was about vladimir
putin biden explained that we're going
to hurt putin by making it illegal for
americans to buy russian energy
this he said will amount to a massive
moral victory for us we're going to feel
great about ourselves and at the same
time it will be a crushing defeat for
the russians who of course deserve it so
it was one of those rare occasions when
we could see the good guys win and the
bad guys lose hooray
ron washington you could almost hear the
feverish applause as biden finished
speaking every constituency loved it the
media agreed that joe biden had never
seen more presidential
democratic officials seem deeply
relieved for once they could talk about
something other than kovit in the
southern border they'd rather be on
offense than defense republican leaders
meanwhile seemed happiest of all they
barked like seals
finally a chance to sound tough and
decisive without making cnn angry thank
you joe biden we can all be john mccain
now you rarely see unity like this in a
city as divided as washington the unity
was so heady in fact so delightful and
intoxicating that no one remembered to
ask the most basic question
why exactly are we doing this what's the
point
is the point to bankrupt vladimir putin
that might be worth doing but this won't
do it putin already has ready markets
around the world for his oil starting in
china in india and turkey so that's not
going to work
maybe the point is to force russian
troops to withdraw from ukraine that
would definitely be worth doing but no
that's not the point either
joe biden will typically say absolutely
anything but even joe biden didn't claim
today that sanctioning russian oil will
end the war in ukraine
because it won't
so who exactly are these sanctions aimed
at
think about it
if you want to identify the target of a
penalty consider who's going to suffer
most from it
and in this case the answer could not be
clear it's middle income americans
they're the ones who were crushed for
two years under covert restrictions
they're the ones who are about to be
pummeled by shutting down more energy
sources notice a theme here the people
in charge hate the middle class above
all
so it's not vladimir putin who's getting
punished
it's american citizens it's you it's not
speculation gas price is already the
highest they have ever been in history
and they're about to get even higher
potentially much much higher so the
price of natural gas and the price of
electricity and food and everything else
you buy that has to be transported more
than 100 yards from where it was made
which is to say every single thing in
your life
this is not good news for you no matter
what washington is currently claiming
you are about to get a lot poorer that's
guaranteed
you'll notice as you watch this clip
that that is the one thing that somehow
joe biden forgot to mention today
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
so lying by omission is pretty simple
you just don't mention the truth you
heard biden do that just there but it
takes something else very different
whether it's hutzpah or delusion or
senility or whatever else explains joe
biden's behavior it takes something like
that to tell a lie like the one you just
heard at the end of biden's statement
quote
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
oh but it simply is true it's
demonstrably true and everyone knows it
on his first day in office biden
single-handedly killed the keystone xl
pipeline then just days before russia
invaded ukraine weirdly biden's
administration shut down all new energy
leases and permits on federal land that
happened vladimir putin did not do that
joe biden did it
watch biden's publicist try to explain
that actually preventing domestic energy
production which they have done
is very different from holding back
domestic energy production
here she is
let me give you the facts here and i
know that can be inconvenient but i
think they're important in this moment
to the contrary we have uh
we have been clear that in the short
term supply must keep up with the demand
where we are and here and around the
world when we make the shift to a secure
clear clean energy future we are one of
the largest producers with a strong
domestic oil and gas industry we have
actually produced more oil it is at
record numbers and we will continue to
produce more oil there are 9 000
approved drilling permits that are not
being used so the suggestion that we are
not allowing companies to drill is
inaccurate the suggestion that that is
what is hindering or preventing gas
prices to come down is inaccurate
let me give you the facts here now when
they say that you know the lies are
coming and indeed in this case they
arrived promptly
because oil companies have not used all
the permits they've received gensake
told us that means this is their fault
they're not trying hard enough to
produce energy they could but they don't
want to
but wait a second gensake
what if there's no oil or gas underneath
the permitted land
in that case energy producers would want
permits for land where the energy is
turns out they don't want dry wells they
want wells that flow
but they're not getting them thanks to
the green new deal lobby that completely
controls this administration they can't
get those permits
and that's what's happening here and if
you doubt it ask anyone who works in the
energy business
jinsaki just lied to you
they are all lying to you you probably
guessed that already but you can't say
it
because if you wonder what these
policies may be doing to your country or
to your family you are selfish and
disloyal in fact you're unpatriotic
because real patriotism is caring about
ukraine first and by the way caring
about ukraine means prolonging a bloody
war in ukraine until the entire country
of ukraine has been destroyed and
millions of ukrainians are refugees we
know we can do it because we did it in
iraq we can do it in ukraine that's
patriotism
once you spell it out it all sounds kind
of complicated so we're going to hand it
over to our late night moral leader
stephen colbert to explain
today the average gas price in america
hit an all-time record high of over four
dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
well turns out a guy who makes 16
million dollars a year is willing to pay
a little more for gas if that's the
right thing to do he's willing to make
that sacrifice because that's the kind
of caring decent man stephen colbert is
now what's true is he just heard that he
doesn't actually use gasoline he drives
150 000 electric car but he will do it
anyway he's the kind of man who will
take you out to dinner and let you pay
and at the end he'll let you leave a big
tip because he cares about the server
sometimes as stephen colbert reminds us
life is about making tough moral choices
and that's especially true now
if at the end of this project this
protracted exercise and social
reorganization achieved through covid
plus or war with russia if at that point
whenever it is we no longer have a
self-sufficient middle class if people
who make under a hundred grand a year
are more desperate and demoralized and
dependent on government than they've
ever been
if the only americans who remain truly
free at that point are the oligarchs
well
at least we can say we help democracy
when mark zuckerberg controls everything
in america you will know it's a truly
democratic system justin trudeau
understands this he ran over members of
his middle class with horses because
that's what it took to preserve
democracy in canada
and then he went farther he seized
truckers bank accounts and then he shut
down a coffee shop that served people
who didn't vote for him that's what
democracy looks like
elizabeth warren was excited when she
saw this kind of democracy at work
warren knows if we're going to preserve
democracy in america if we're going to
fight russia then elizabeth warren is
going to need fingertip control of your
family's finances now and always and by
the way don't try to hide anything from
elizabeth warren saying cryptocurrency
because if you do elizabeth warren will
know
you are working for vladimir putin as i
mentioned earlier we're going after two
things trying to squeeze the russian
economy and also trying to squeeze those
oligarchs right
the problem is we're doing that only
through the formal banking system and
we're doing a good job on that and that
is very effective it's historic i'm a
hundred percent behind it
but there's a there's a hole in the dike
here and the whole is crypto in other
words
you gotta pick it crypto
if you want to continue to uh uh trade
and provide the trading platforms and so
on in the wallets
you can do business in russia or you can
do business in the united states but you
can't do business in both
here's an idea let's keep dumb people
and crazed partisan demagogues away from
our financial system and our power grid
they can keep the sociology department
have fun
but why don't you stay away from the
fundamentals that keep the country
running how's that sound that was the
arrangement for decades but no longer
you must submit to total personal
control by your responsible lunatics
like elizabeth warren or you can serve
russia as she put it quote
you can't do business in both
and by the way you better not complain
about this good americans love higher
gas prices they love suffering for a
cause they don't understand cnn looked
into it and that's what they found watch
people we've spoken to over the last
couple weeks they're okay paying higher
prices if it means holding russia
accountable for what they are doing in
ukraine but these prices are likely
going to creep higher
turns out americans are delighted to be
poor and helpless they love it because
poverty means holding russia accountable
not putin's poverty that's not going to
happen your poverty
well how exactly does your poverty hold
putin accountable cena didn't ask that
question but the polling company
rasmussen did ask that's what they do
they asked this question quote if a
wider war breaks out in europe should
the u.s military be involved pretty
simple question the answer was not
simple though the answer varied by
income this may not surprise you the
people who actually fight our wars the
people making under 30 grand a year were
overwhelmingly opposed to this war only
37 percent of them supported military
action
and then it changed going up the richer
and more cut off from physical reality
people got the more ardently they
supported war with russia and it turns
out that's the subset you see those are
the people on television the people with
fake jobs and inherited money they're
totally for it and therefore because
they're going to pay no cost but they'll
still get a few virtuous about promoting
it
then they'll tune in to stephen colbert
at night with a clean heart
as for the americans who will do the
actual fighting and then the suffering
here at home they don't count because in
a democracy you can safely ignore the
middle class
and so our leaders are doing that watch
but the truth is which we should be
thinking about the fact that when
americans
go to
fill up their cars
that they should think about sticking it
to poot when they put that uh
uh
gas handle and and
the gas
in your gas tank
uh it's gonna cost a little more and
part of it's gonna be because of russia
and just stick it to poot
now here in america we got to be ready
for the fact that will drive up oil
prices that will drive up gas prices um
and if we are really standing with
ukraine we have to be prepared to absorb
that ban all russian imports into the
united states in terms of oil and gas
four percent of our oil supply comes
from russia we can easily make that up
so what we haven't done yet
is go after oil and gas sector in russia
that's the achilles heel to putin's war
machine
they don't care about you at all they
have complete contempt for you and your
interest notice they don't even bother
to apologize to you for what they're
about to do to you and your family which
will change your life for not
overstating it now who are they the
first two men you saw that montage were
democrats the third was lindsey graham
will let you decide what he is apart
from utterly loathsome obviously
but we have to tell you that virtually
every elected republican in washington
dc is fully on board with this which is
another way of saying they are totally
committed to screwing their own supposed
constituency which would be america's
shrinking desperate middle class those
are the people who vote republican and
this is what they get in return
no apology
shafted
it's hard to remember a betrayal at this
scale and yes we have been here before
by the way
we've been in conflicts with russia for
a long time
the united states traded with the
russians through the height of the cold
war
when the soviet union the united states
had nuclear weapons pointed right at
each other and we worried one might go
off we traded with joseph stalin in the
middle of his terror at the very moment
he was murdering four million yes
ukrainians
that happened and then we armed stalin
we armed the soviet army as he was
killing ukrainians and the new york
times endorsed all of it
but now because putin invaded ukraine
effectively encouraged by the biden
administration to do that which is true
because that happened we are going to
send billions of dollars to the saudi
theocracy and then to the iranians and
then to nicholas maduro in venezuela and
at the same time we're going to embrace
green energy which means giving the
government of china complete control
over a power grid here in america that's
our plan are you confused by it don't be
it's a moral victory let us know when
you get tired of winning hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else